you know how many universities are
teaching classes to become an
entrepreneur today hundreds do you know
why people are starting to figured out
your starter figured out you know who's
the what generation is really figuring
it out it's so interesting to me
it's boomers do you know why bloomers
are figuring it out because they have
the most experience in the workforce and
they know it doesn't work anymore
and Millennials and Gen Xers are not
asking anything questioning anything
they're just doing what boomers did
they're going to getting a job they're
not realizing the original reason why
nine-to-five job was created
do you know originally you know this
nine-to-five is only a two-year period
thing anyone knows it's like nine to
five has not been on for thousands of
years it's only 80 years old do you know
why we agreed to work 9:00 to 5:00 and
you know who invented 9:00 to 5:00 by
what was the company that invented 9:00
to 5:00 Ford Motor Company at that time
Ford was the Godfather of companies in
Detroit whatever they did everybody else
did so here's how was hey Vicky I would
like to have you give 30 years of your
life to my company Ford Motor Company
and Vicky says what she goes like this
and she says what your question would be
what what do I get for giving you 30
years and I said I'm sorry I'm Ford she
says I'm sorry what am I going to get
for my 30 years I guess that's the third
question okay you give me 30 years of
your life staying with me at the company
I'm going to give you a 30 year pension
plan wait a minute so I work for you 30
years in you're going to give me my
income I am fair deal boom we shake
hands good negotiation